speaking of Arizona I was also one of
the first people to have Carrie Lake on
Carrie Lake former media member former
Democrat former Obama voter got red pill
then this woman some people swallowed
the red pill this woman snorted the red
pill and you may remember this one when
a CNN reporter wanted to ask her a
couple questions
well we're six feet apart do you have a
minute to chat
um I'll do an interview okay as long as
it airs on CNN plus does that still
exist I didn't think so because the
people don't like what you guys are
peddling which is propaganda thank you
I mean like how much better do you want
it like that was just silent but deadly
just think you don't even know it's like
20 minutes later you already swallowed
the poison nothing you could do now lady
just absolutely perfect and she has what
I think Carrie lake has done perhaps
better than anyone else in this election
cycle is map out how do you fight you
guys are propaganda propagandists enough
of this nonsense